this is one thing that makes men subject
to
toxic ideologies in my opinion is that
there's this thirst for significance
and so if you don't get that
significance in your day-to-day life and
then someone has some idea being like oh
you know why things are going badly for
you because these people are keeping you
down and here's how we can fight them
then you start getting attracted to that
because it makes you part of something
important yes
and men crave that yes
there's a crave to take things like be a
man and like that's yours or go get it
um
and that can be done
well or very poorly in the way that men
approach women and things like that
there's the competition the ego the
hubris but also turns into apathy or
hate or racism you know these darker
pieces of otherness or
other people are causing this
and so to me as a society we need to
talk about that and understand that
um frederick douglass what did he say
it's in your book he said
it's easier to build strong children
than to repair broken men and when men
start getting these seeds it gets very
very very difficult to
to come back and i've seen that in terms
a lot of them industry work my dad does
you have men they're just
they're just broken
[Music]
this week on ford zach and i talk about
american masculinity what is going wrong
what could go right this week on forward
[Music]
we are back and this week we're going to
talk about a subject that's near and
dear to zack's heart to my heart to your
heart
manhood we did promise this last week
yes we talked a little bit about video
games and we said this is a deeper
conversation
about frankly it's societies and
specifically men's relationship with
their
masculinity and what it means to be a
man and and how that bleeds into our
politics in various ways the social
consequences of it so i i was just
looking at the vote totals for 2020
and trump won
among
non-college-educated white men
66 percent to 31
i mean like that that's the core of
trump's base
and
one of the things that i found in my
book uh the war on normal people seen
here plug plug uh and this is why i ran
for president is that we had eliminated
about five million manufacturing jobs
over a period of 15
17 years went from 17 million to 12
million
now
the bulk of that in my view was due to
automation some people say globalization
you could you know parse out different
percentages but the reality is
america lost
five million manufacturing jobs over
that period right and the most mostly
mostly men
so three-quarters of those
manufacturing jobs were held by men
now if you imagine men working in a
factory a lot of them are not college
educated
so when those men left their jobs lost
their jobs they often
uh
were
put adrift
in the economy uh in a way that was very
very punishing and punitive and for a
lot of them things went south very very
dramatically where you had massive
surges in
substance abuse
in alcoholism
in deaths of despair
and this to me was the driving force
behind trump's
victory
and that bleeds into the way society
talks about masculinity because there
was a point in the not so distant past
where if you were a non-college educated
man
you could live a fine middle class life
you could get married you could have
kids make a living manufacturing was one
of the most prevalent jobs
in the economy for
men without college degrees and then you
get rid of a lot of those jobs and then
the bottom falls out for a lot of these
men right
and
what we wanted to talk about today was
one i wanted to like unpack what you
wrote in your book
but i also
and i'm personal my so my dad was uh
still does a lot of work in men's
ministry and so i've i grew up in that
and i've seen
what happens to men
if
various external factors happen they
don't have a great relationship with
their own masculinity their own role as
a man
and i think i want this conversation to
be helpful for both men and women
listening to this because i think the
conversation we're having right now on a
national scale and what's coming out on
men i think is massively destructive um
i think you agree i i do and i think
that it's taking place along party lines
a particular way it's taking place along
educational lines
and i i really dearly do want to unpack
it and help people understand yeah so
let's dive in i got my laptop on my lap
for this episode because i i dove in so
your book i want let's talk about
you pointed out
these numbers are going to
blow your mind again like they did when
i first read it but you pointed out a
lot of problems with boys and men in the
book you're holding a couple i'll say
right now
a study by mit poverty researcher
david outur otter otter showed that when
manufacturing work becomes less
available the proportion of men who get
married in affected communities declined
so the average male wages have declined
since 1990 in real terms and a pew study
that showed that many men are foregoing
or delaying marriage because they do not
feel financially secure the same study
said that for women having a steady job
was a single biggest factor when they
were looking for a spouse
yeah and that there's a table on page
126 in my book where it says the
proportion of working-class adults who
get married
has plummeted from 70 to 1970. so if
you're a working-class adult you want to
get married odds were you could find a
mate and
have a family to only 45 today so now
there's like a less than 50 50 chance
that you're going to get married if
you're a working class adult so think
about all of those
uh people but we're just going to talk
about men for a second that never get
married and a lot of that is because
their economic prospects have dimmed and
the reality is that if you're a woman
and you look around at your
potential partners
and you see that hey they don't have
steady jobs and they're shiftless and
you're like oh like maybe i don't want
to marry this dude and start a family
and so you're seeing marriage rates go
down
uh
across the board
the other stat that was crazy and you
talked about the number of men who are
unemployed or out of the workforce um
there was an atlantic article that said
there were 10 million men one of six
american uh prime age 25 54 men are
either unemployed or out of the
workforce yahoo has a new study recently
that said that number's one-third it's
going up and then going forth you end up
with other things that come to this so
you have
people are still having kids so you end
up with kids born of single mothers or
single parents it's like 41
of american kids are born to unmarried
moms
and so if you know some of them grow up
in functionally two-parent households in
various ways they're like two people
that are living together but they're
just not married a lot of them though
are growing up in single-parent
households right and if you and if
you're growing up in a single parent
household there's an 85 90 chance that
you're growing up with the mom there are
of course single fathers out there but
they're outnumbered you know eight or
nine to one right by the single moms so
the single mom has a girl then the girl
has a strong role model and the outcomes
are okay if the single mom has a boy
unfortunately boys are more sensitive to
parental time input yes than
girls so if you have a single mom let's
say she's working
and then you're a boy and you're left
your own devices you're more likely to
have behavioral problems academic
problems maturation problems and so
you're seeing this in schools around the
country there are a lot of boys who are
struggling in various ways academically
much more likely to have adhd
or autism
and so
then they go into
high school
college
girls do better academically
girls do better in high school they
vastly outnumber boys in terms of high
school valedictorians as one example
these numbers are crazy by the way girls
kick men's ass in school
for a number of reasons but um
yes with or without
the society disintegrating um
it's kind of an international phenomenon
too which is that girls are better than
boys at school
through grade 12.
now that plays out in terms of
college enrollments where about 58
of american college students are women
42
men
at this point colleges are even leaning
a little bit being like hey we'd like to
have some more guys i think that they're
you know frankly lowering their
standards a bit trying to keep the
gender balance from going completely out
of whack so there are all of these
differences um throughout development
and and this is where i want to talk
about kind of the the two sides of the
coin where you have one side of the coin
which is the
uh the non-college educated part of the
population right and then you have the
college educated part of the population
which do you want to lead off with let's
start with non-college that's kind of
where you dove in at first right yes
so if you look at the non-college
educated population
again the opportunities for men have
been dramatically reduced in number
and so the these men and one of the
numbers that shocked me when i was
researching this book was that at this
point the health outcomes for
non-college-educated white
men are the same as they are for uh
black men
um and there used to be a huge
difference you should be a huge gap
right and then now those
those outcomes have converged in part
because black outcomes you know improved
in some places but like white outcomes
got worse
so
and again if you have
non-college-educated women then they
look at these potential partners and say
pass
you know and sometimes they'll have a
kid and they'll be like look i'm better
off uh trying to raise this kid myself
or multiple kids myself without uh this
male partner um who is the father
because you have high levels of
substance abuse and other problems
um so that's the non-college-educated
phenomenon because we've gotten rid of
most paths to the middle class
for non-college educated men if you look
at that opportunity set manufacturing
was one of the most common
the other most common jobs are
retail and sales food service and food
prep truck driving and transportation
and uh administration
and clerical clerical work
so administration and clerical work and
retail and sales sku female
truck driving skews dramatically now
it's like 94
male manufacturing uh was 75 male it's
not quite as dramatic but it's still
uh you know 70 plus men
um so
the the opportunity set for men is not
what it once was and nothing new has
come to replace it if you don't have a
college
[Music]
degree real talk folks how is your
mental health in 2022 is there something
preventing you from achieving your goals
anything interfering
with your happiness
we want you guys to check out our
sponsor betterhelp.com
yang i've used this
since they started sponsoring this show
andrew's used it i've recommended it to
friends it is a easy way to assess what
you need from mental standpoint and get
matched with your own licensed
professional therapist you can connect
in a safe and private online environment
it's so convenient you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's
awesome and it's not a crisis line guys
it's not self-help it's professionally
professional counseling done securely
online you can talk to your counselor at
any time you can do them once a week at
your cadence fantastic so whether you're
dealing with depression or stress
anxiety relationships or trauma grief
for me it was just getting my mindset
right to operate
in this let's call the postcovid world
right everything's changed for me was
getting on track betterhelp was
fantastic on there it's convenient
professional affordable and i want you
guys to check it out so
hopefully you guys can start living a
happier life today and as a listener to
this podcast you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help
dot com
slash yang
[Music]
so
the jobs are drying up
the family is driving up the opportunity
to have a solid mate is drying up but we
there's a different men and women who
are in this similar situation who maybe
lose their job the 25 of women that were
in manufacturing losing their same job
they are responding different to this
economic situation women are more
adaptable than men to that kind of
change in circumstance they're more
likely to go back to school as one
example if you look at men who are
unemployed
their propensity to go to church or
volunteer at a non-profit actually goes
down not up
when they're unemployed geez even though
they have more time
so one of the issues for uh
for guys is that without a livelihood
their sense of self-worth plummets and
then their
desire to go out and volunteer also
plummets do you know why that is i mean
i think that's like the core of this
and we've been trying to get to better
equality of opportunity for men and
women but men and women are so different
and the numbers are screaming off the
page
i have thoughts too but it goes back to
kind of where we talk about video games
two men are more likely to dive into
video games or spend a lot of their new
free time spent on the computer in this
situation why do you think that is so
here's a quote from george orwell
a man with no means of filling up time
is as miserable out of work as a dog on
the chain
saying that if a guy there's another
saying you know idle hands are the
devil's tool devil's tools i think
they're referring to men
primarily so women deal with idleness
better than men yes um women in a way
are not ever truly idle uh you know like
that they'll be able to improve their
environment uh improve themselves go
back to school
uh spend time with each other uh that
they don't have the same kind of
negative social externality
pattern that men do men who are idle
start gambling drinking
doing drugs and
uh become antisocial pretty quickly
right
and
a lot of people listening to those have
seen some version of this in their own
lives maybe they felt that and it's
something that i will say i personally
uh sympathize with a great deal one of
the things i
i say in the war on normal people is
that every guy has the seeds of a failed
man inside of him right and so you can
see when someone does fail when when a
guy fails you're like oh my gosh like
that
could be me because you kind of know
yourself you know that there's some part
of you that just wants to go to the
basement and
hang out and
play video games and avoid the world
what are those seeds
in your eyes like what are the seeds of
a dysfunctional
man
you know what i'm saying like i think
every guy
well one of one of the one of the things
i joke about with evelyn sometimes
is that if you're an unmarried man
you your life will likely end earlier
like yeah you will die by the numbers by
the numbers you will die what is it
seven ten years earlier yeah it's almost
a decade right and if you are an
unmarried woman
no effect on your lifespan like guys do
not make women live longer
[Laughter]
we have no impact yes women uh make guys
live longer right and now that i am
married i understand why
um i also so i'm 47 i have friends who
are unmarried and may never marry and
you can see that the kind of returns on
male activities are going down
over time like i am so grateful to be
married in part because
the things that you get a charge out of
as a young man give you a little bit
less joy
as you as you get older and so you start
shifting gears where now i get pleasures
of you know like uh being a dad and like
bringing
the boys to a sporting event and living
vicariously through through them
and mellowing out and watching
uh you know succession with evelyn or
whatever it is
so you know you'll like these
simple pleasures
um
and i think the seeds of failure for
guys are that
we need to feel some degree of
progress
achievement
stature appreciation virility
appreciation
and video games
form a perfect avenue for this because
if you spend a bit of time you get
stronger you get more powerful you get
richer you get uh more friends you get
to win right this competition
uh and so here's a quote
from jonathan gottschall who writes
about gaming virtual worlds give back
what has been scooped out of modern life
it gives us back community a feeling of
competence and a sense of being an
important person whom people depend on
yes yes and that is what a lot of what a
job does yeah and then what what's
fascinating to me and this is what i
kind of want to get into is that
the job or that sense of duty or
responsibility or appreciation or
respect that men are craving when it
when it's not there
there's seeds of the seeds of
dysfunction seeds of dysfunction
dysfunctional masculinity masculinity or
the dysfunctional male
start to seep in start to plant and
those are either i wrote down i was like
it's either thinking with the wrong head
which is the uh
sure the robin williams quotes like god
gave men two heads and only enough blood
to run one at a time it's probably i
think it's accurate i think avoiding
responsibility like almost hiding and
numbing the pain whether that's drugs or
alcohol or kind of that escapism
this is one thing that makes men subject
to
toxic ideologies in my opinion is that
there's this thirst for significance
and so if you don't
get that significance in your day-to-day
life and then someone has some idea
being like oh you know why things are
going badly for you because these people
are keeping you down and here's how we
can fight them then you start getting
attracted to that because it makes you
part of something important yes
and men crave that yes
there's a crave to take things like be a
man like that's yours or go get it
and that can be done
well or very poorly in the way that men
approach women and things like that
there's the competition the ego the
hubris but also turns into apathy or
hate or racism you know these darker
pieces of
otherness or other people are causing
this
and so to me as a society we need to
talk about that and understand that
frederick douglass what did he say it's
in your book he said uh
it's easier to build strong children
than to repair broken men
and when men start getting these seeds
it gets very very very difficult to
to come back and i've seen that in terms
of a lot of them industry work my dad
does you have men they're just
they're just broken they're beat this is
in some ways a grossly oversimplified
way to think about the struggle that
america is going through where you have
this
uh disintegrating way of life for
millions of men and a need for
significance um and anger
and and the the question is can we
manage
this process in a way that
keeps people strong and whole and
healthy and even understanding what's
happening right or is it going to be
like uh
you know oh like screw you like your
perspective is unimportant um you know
like we don't care about you uh and and
so one of the things i want to switch to
is what's happening among the college
educated cohort that ends up in in many
ways obscuring a lot of these struggles
correct yes so let's go there
so among the college educated crew it's
it's a very different environment
so let's say you have 58 women 42 men in
college
that might not seem that dramatically
different but it's it's a lot and over
time it gets so if the numbers if you
change the number slightly to 60 40
um what that would mean is that
one-third of college-educated women
um will not have a college-educated man
to marry
when they want to get married and
that is
the case
um in part because college-educated
women will essentially not consider any
non-college educated man to get married
in most circumstances yeah by the
numbers by the by the numbers right so
you'll wind up with a very significant
number of
college-educated women who will
not marry i mean they might decide to
have kids independently
and then they're going into environments
and it varies wildly by industry but the
the overwhelming narrative is that if
you look at certain environments
finance tech
media to you know
a large extent some of the most highly
visible
industries they tend to be somewhat male
dominated and so
the movement is for women who are going
into this environment say hey we
outnumber men
at the
entry levels but then you go up to the
top let's say it's a law firm so i have
some experience with that environment
yeah the number of law school graduates
is essentially a gender gender parody
now male female
but if you look at the partnerships it's
like very very male dominated right um
and so
the active
movement is to say hey this stuff is out
of whack we need more female ceos more
female partners we need more female
board members
and so the narrative is around
men marginalizing women in these
environments which is a very different
environment than what we were just
discussing which is like there are you
know legions of men who
don't have um meaningful opportunities
among the less educated set so in among
the educated universe it's like hey why
do guys have all the power and money
right
and our response to that has been
promoting women faster i guess slowly
but surely like we are i mean have you
seen
people or companies start to level the
playing field or you still think it's a
it's still very very out of whack
is it improving marginally
my my perspective on this
is that a lot of these environments are
almost
intrinsically
um
women unfriendly and somewhat family
unfriendly yeah where and you worked on
wall street so you might be able to
speak to this so you worked in like a
slightly gentler sector world generally
so we have this uh winner take all
marketplace and if you look at finance
and tech and media
the winner take all dynamics are all
consuming where it's like look if we get
this deal or we get this market or
whatnot like we're all going to be rich
and then if we don't we are all going to
be poor
so yeah so everyone needs to go go go
and you come and be like look you need
to work uh you know
around the clock you need to be
available all the time and you do it for
years on end um and then you'll reap
these massive rewards
um and so these cultures are
like completely subject to
um these market dynamics and so then if
a woman enters this organization is like
hey like maybe i don't feel like working
70 or 80 hours a week
if you adopted the same standard for
everyone like women would look up and be
like you know let's say i want to have a
kid at some point i actually want some
some like you know family time and the
rest of it um then they'll naturally
self-select and be like hey let me
leave this place at a certain point um
and then the organization will be back
to square one being like you know where
all the women in senior management
leadership right so there are certain
cosmetic things they could do around it
being like maybe we should have more
generous policies and this but the
culture itself is going to be geared
towards the market that they're in right
oh no do i think that this is great no
do i think there should be a four day
work week which by the way would would
end up helping us
help you know like help everyone because
like you know this is burning dudes out
too like this is like everyone's kind of
going crazy
um so that it's it's not purely a
gendered thing so i would love it if
organizations adopted more uh humane
cultures and
paces and you didn't have to answer uh
your phone and your email after a
certain hour and like the rest like all
that stuff would make me very happy
right but i i will will suggest that if
even if you made these cultural shifts
um it's a very very different struggle
than the struggle that most
men or families are experiencing because
like the tendency is for media
employees to think of things in the same
way as happening in their company right
but you know what's happening in their
company is completely distinct from
what's happening in like you know some
working class town in missouri
[Music]
i've always considered myself a feminist
mainly because i grew up i grew up with
a badass mom like my mom was uh
like on one hand like a super mom from
uh like the traditional definition of
like the minivan and the pto that sort
of thing but she always worked she was a
special ed teacher but then did
part-time teaching and tutoring and then
now is still working to this day and
well in their 60s
and
i mean the town like i mean the town
gave her she was citizen of the year in
uh where i grew up and things like that
but she is well known for being just a
remarkable kind of a badass worker a
machine
her mom was a nurse when she was growing
up like i've grown up with like my
grandma's a nurse like my uh my dad's
family had strong women like
his mom worked like i've grew up growing
up with that and so i've always kind of
what you're saying before
i've always had this when the feminist
movement was really getting teeth in
like the 90s and 2000s and as i got out
of college
as
an ally to this movement i was like
you're right like i think
the patriarchy has gone a little too far
i think uh [ __ ] men have gone a
little too far it's like important to
take a step back maybe not say anything
like it's
we've had our turn and because of this
good things have happened objectively
like there's more women in stem women in
sports i think you've seen a lot of good
come from it but my problem that i have
with the feminist movement today
because
in certain environments it's sidelining
men and boys or not focusing on
their relationship with masculinity
where they're growing up as me or as men
or growing up as boys
it's creating weak men
and
when there are more weak men
the people who suffer the most are women
like having weak men hurts women and
what do i mean by weak men that's
and what we're talking about they don't
the the seeds of dysfunctional man are
i've taken root and you start to see
more apathy more hate more destruction
more pornography more alcohol like
everything you're talking about in the
numbers and that what happens then what
are the social consequences and you talk
about them in your book but it's
domestic violence going up it's sexual
violence growing up it's more me too
incident it's suicides and drug
overdoses like these hurt women
so generally speaking more than men so i
100 agree that there are all of these
ills that are born of men who are not
thriving right and so we should be
trying to help men thrive in various
ways you'd have to draw a straighter
line for me in terms of how you think
the feminist movement is
is increasing the
weakness among men and this is not
so
so my feeling on the
like the feminist movement i generally
consider myself pro just about
everything on like under the sun for
women um like any of the policies
they're advocating totally for yes one
of the things that
makes me concerned about it is that it
seems to
sometimes
ignore the struggling and failing of
um
male figures pretty much like hey if
you're a guy and you're failing like
you know
tough luck's on you like you're
kind of like the source of the problem
um and like i that
if that attitude were widespread then i
can see why you're saying uh hey this is
not helping guys
uh thrive is that what you're saying
what i'm saying is what you're seeing in
frankly are primary schools in early
education where girls are dominating
boys and you have we have this
environment where we think we need to
we need to do more for the women which
is what the feminist movement is about
but you're seeing the guys get
shellacked and that's where where the
kids are they're more likely to get
suspended they're more likely to drop
out of school they're more likely to go
down the list
and i think
not helping boys and men or boys in
particular understand their masculinity
and their relationship to that at a
younger age and then telling them oh you
need you can't do that because like
because you're a boy or we need to let
the girls go first
i don't think is helping and i know that
feels right because i do think men have
been shitty this entire time but the
problem is
some of the tactics we are using do you
have do you have insight or data or
studies in terms of what's happening at
the grade school level and how it's
affecting because so are there boys
failing at the school level at much
higher rates than would be in my uh
opinion acceptable like yes like there
are boys failing uh right and left
is that because they're being treated
differently in school i just haven't
seen the any so the numbers i have are
the typical boy is a year and a half
behind the typical girl in reading and
writing unless i buy it um
full-time enrollments in college are
substantially more female
than yes uh suspended more likely to be
suspended male more likely to drop out
or be held back a grade men they're
three times more likely to receive a
diagnosis of adhd yes more likely to get
involved in in crime alcohol and drugs
yes um
girls more likely to attempt suicide but
boar's more boys more likely to succeed
a typical year this was 97 data as the
number's gotten worse since this and the
article i pulled was older but uh
it was of the 97 for example of the
almost five four thousand four hundred
young people age five to 24 committing
suicide 700 were female and 3 700 were
men
so so i i agree that the outcomes for
boys are
um much more adverse and you have all
all of these structural deficiencies
you're saying what about the feminist
movement is not doing it or
like yeah how's like the so the so the
feminist movement one of the issues to
me is that it's obscuring all these
struggles among men and boys okay um
because it's saying like hey
men your mistreatment uh and
marginalization of us is the problem
which implicitly puts men in the
position of success and power which is
true
if you look at the the
uh you know
super lucrative fields uh like and a
bunch of other things like it is true
that right men are the top layer correct
um
but it seems to obscure all of these
struggles and failings among men and
that part
pains me greatly and that's i think
that's what that is what i'm saying in
that we have this narrative that the men
are the problem and the men are
it's it's skewed towards helping men and
by the numbers it's not and in fact if a
man does a man does
call this out or say he's struggling or
is struggling with in school or that
sort of thing you're not seeing
the same help or resources and
prioritization from either educators or
the media in that sense in a sense men
feel more ashamed one of the things that
i see very clearly and i'd love people
to understand this is that when you
think about the feminist movement i
think
it tends to be most prevalent among uh
women who are college educated or like
you know
in the educated classes and so then i
think women in those environments
are
looking up and saying hey why why do men
run everything like why is it hard to
get ahead right and and then that's the
nature of the conversation right and
then you have uh the
non-educated folks where it's like you
have men failing right and left your
boys failing right and left um and then
if they look up and see this
conversation up here it tends to
miss some of like the you know the
central
uh struggles and it's a little bit just
environment specific right you know like
like do i think that women are
being harassed discriminated against in
like the average
uh investment bank yes yes yeah is that
a problem yes so like so so they're not
mutually exclusive right it's like you
you have
this set of issues and then you but
i i think that often
it's getting presented as if this
college-educated professional layer is
is the is the entirety of society and
like that's my issue with it uh is just
like look is the waitress at the diner
going to benefit
um you know like that to me would be
that the test
um it's one reason why you know i'm for
things like universal base game
companies like you know that that would
help the waitress the diner also not get
harassed right uh you know like there
there are different versions of it
the single biggest thing we could do is
economically empower
individuals so that they're not subject
to
exploitation harassment etc and that
would help women much more than
than men um across the board though i'm
sure would help men too who are in in
various environments and so this is one
of the cases i was making on the
presidential which i failed at um was
trying to go to feminist saying like
look universal basic income is the most
pro-feminist policy under the sun
correct uh you know if you just think of
that victim of uh domestic violence who
wants to be able to walk away but can't
because
you know that they're economically uh
captive that waitress who wants to leave
that diner because the boss is an
[ __ ] but can't because they can't
even miss a shift without like you know
the bottom falling out like this is the
most feminist thing we could do
um and this other stuff you know like i
get it it's important but like this
stuff is not as central to the
uh the problems of women writ large and
again i failed at this right
well i failed in making that case right
successfully let against
so if there are any
people listening to this right now who
are like hey like i'd love to make basic
income you know like the central part of
the feminist agenda that i wish it were
like please please please like you know
take it up so
we have a system
at the educational level k through 12
where it is
benefiting women right now more than men
by the numbers the women or let's say
women are thriving more
than the men
fine great that's what we want we want
to build strong healthy women the
problem is when the men who are not
succeeding in those environments are not
just getting beat by the girls darn
getting the second place trophy whatever
it is
they're disintegrating
they're disintegrating and when they
disintegrate it causes a ton of problems
for everybody but substantially more
problems for women
and
for example
right now we i mean what's our
conversation around mental health it's
it's not a it's not a conversation
around men and it needs to be when you
talk about mental health it frankly is a
male problem mental health issues are
three times worse in men
than i mean go down this suicides death
of despair triple
for men particularly white men in this
country and that's who's we're talking
about failing in these systems and what
are happening what happens when those
men are weak
disaster for women in particular it's a
disaster for everyone um so one of the
the problems with this phenomenon is
that being good at school is now seen as
uh something girls do feminine yeah as
feminine uh as more more boys grow up
without their father in the home and as
women are viewed as the more stable
achievers boys and girls alike come to
see males as having a lower achievement
orientation and less aptitude for higher
education
college becomes something that many
girls but only some boys do the opposite
of the earlier cultural norm yep
you know what the biggest cause of crime
is stronger than race or income
lack of a father
how nuts is that yeah so so you're
seeing this decimation of the
traditional two-parent family household
right you're seeing all these adverse
outcomes and
boys struggle more
uh and then you have a culture that
completely
ignores any struggles among
working class boys and men and just
being like oh you know like that nothing
to see there like the real problem is
male oppress oppression yes of
women let's say not getting enough women
in these roles or we're not yeah no no
it's very narrow and institutionalized
that's my issue with it is that like if
if you're a college educated woman and
you look up at your professional
environment and be like hey there should
be more women in charge sure yes i agree
it's like you know but that can't be
like the focus of the struggle because
like there are a lot of women who are
not in that professional services
environment there you know but like
that's my issue with it is that it seems
again a little bit uh
it's just a bit too narrow
in my opinion right um
there's data to back that up i mean
equality has gone up in and again for
most of the things that people are
advocating for it's just you know like
when i spoke to women's group groups
when i was running for president i was
like just think bigger think like
they think about
about true economic you know freedom and
so one of the the problems is that
if you're held captive to market-based
dynamics and rewards
um then
you know it's going to wind up again
with like winner take all right um
economics and like certain very
male-dominated environments it's like
look you got to like try to rewrite the
rules of the economy so that it's not
rewarding all these things at a super
high level don't just go into the
organization take the rules for granted
and be like you know like women should
be sharing in these like rewards for
being
frankly in many cases just like totally
insane
which is probably the wall street
experience i cannot tell you how many
young women that
were working for me or i was asked to
mentor whether through the analyst
program associate program things like
that and they said to me every single
time like i don't have either any or
many
strong female role models in this
company
it's because in order to get to the top
at a certain level the women are acting
like men and those men are also acting
like psychos in the sense that you're
just capitalist market driven right and
so women and men are selling their souls
at the top and there's young women in
particular like i don't want to be like
that right um and you look at them and
be like i'm not sure you should yeah
like i've said i don't even want to be
that was my
looking for responsibility
this isn't a place right and that's
that's hard um because men are able to
have it all in that sense there are
there's there were not a lot but there
were a few men that i thought balanced
that kind of capitalist society because
frankly and that is a conversation on
gender roles and why men are allowed to
do that things like that allowed is the
wrong term but i think you know what i
mean one of the things i was very open
about on the presidential is when people
said to me something like hey thank you
for doing this i say thank my wife
because i could not do this if not for
evelyn right
making certain choices
that i appreciate all the time
um yeah yeah the but i guess my point
that i was making
is i i think this is missing in the
feminist conversation that if you want
to protect women and create a stress
create a society of strong women
you need to have a society of strong men
i agree and that is counter-intuitive it
doesn't make any sense on the face of it
until you look into any of them well
well this this is part of it too is that
there's like a zero sum power
differential thing it's like hey you
have too much
give some back and so it it ends up
being like uh
us or them
uh
you know uh whereas
in this context it's like you know
demanding again in these professional
service environments like should they
try and open it up yes
like you know should we try to open it
up for the these struggling
boys and girls uh you know who aren't
giving a a meaningful
shot or a path in this economy yes like
it's
the the greater
problem
is that we have been cast into this
mild obsession with various identity
categories
and it's being presented as zero sum
it's like look you know the problem is
the
like person in this category and that
they have too much and you know that
that's the problem right yeah like and
so
if you put that in terms of gender then
it ends up again missing all of the
struggles uh among men of certain
backgrounds in certain environments yeah
and and one of the things i loved about
your book was
was so mind-blowing was that you talked
about folks
that were working class or not making a
lot of money at the poverty line or so
and how miserable they were and how hard
it was and then you talked about the one
percent and what they're doing they have
a ton of money and they're equally as
miserable
um and so it's killing all of us
i wanted to ask though okay universal
basic income mindset of abundance would
solve a lot of this particularly for
empowering women frankly i think this
would if you're talking about women
handling idleness better
ubi allows you to be somewhat idle um or
not working all the time for your
existence it ends up
recognizing
yeah work that right now the market
values at zero correct which includes
caregiving
parenting you know like a lot of other
things that women do disproportionately
yes
[Music]
the other the next question though is
like okay let's say biden
the next two presidents don't pass ubi
they don't prioritize it um or there's
one reason by the way why i'm so
excited about the child tax credit
because it's close yeah like it's so
good yes and it it does start to to
put money in the hands of parents uh who
again are going to be disproportionately
women start recognizing some of the work
that's happening which is going to be
done by disproportionately women so what
my question is helps keep families
together because if you have a bunch of
men who are unemployed you start giving
them money
right now the vast majority are probably
there's gonna be some that are more
entrepreneurial or get out of the
basement start moving some start
becoming strong and whole get repaired
but probably most
are going to use that as their
their video game budget for the the
month or whatever it is right and start
spending it on things that are
not necessarily great
what can and maybe the answer is nothing
because we're not good at this but can
the government do anything
to kick-start this can and it's both
it's repairing broken men
and then
building strong boys
in the future like what are government
policies to do that that aren't as grand
as ubi is there anything governments can
do or businesses like what should be
done
i've believed for a long time that the
best thing you can do for just about
anyone is give them an opportunity that
they're excited about uh that that
stretches them yes so
ideally speaking you would create a vast
array of opportunities for people but
i'm just going to focus on men for this
conversation where men have different
educational backgrounds uh that are a
good fit for them that they're excited
about so let's say you have for example
a giant infrastructure program is that
going to employ a bunch of men of
different educational backgrounds yes
love it let's do that yep uh you know
like should we be
putting money into the hands of
consumers so that it can flow to small
businesses that might need to hire more
people at every different skill level
yes we should do more of that
uh should we be putting money into
nonprofits schools there are many
agencies that might be able to help
create certain opportunities and if you
look at different categories of
opportunities
like i am for the government as like uh
you know you you have to have the
government uh play a role in some of
this stuff uh i do think the government
creating a job is like you know like the
least attractive mixed result yeah like
like directly where the government just
says hey i'm gonna hire this person
because if the government just says hey
i'm going to hire this person then
uh you know that then you essentially
need to pay for it in perpetuity for
that job to continue existing right um
there are some government jobs that we
need more of and we should 100 do and
there are others like yeah you know like
a little bit less clear
so you'd prefer like a degree of
adaptability and feedback
built in um so it's one reason why if
you did something stimulative
stimulative of small businesses that's
ideal because the small businesses then
hire people in the vicinity and then
it's very very
feedback oriented and um you know and
you don't necessarily need to pay for it
forever like maybe they work at that
small business for a few years then move
on to another and et cetera et cetera
like those things
uh would be the ideal this stuff is all
heading the opposite direction i mean
like the labor force participation rate
during covet has dropped significantly
people are fleeing jobs right and left
for a variety of reasons
and every time people flee the workforce
i get really nervous because
a lot of people will end up
atrophying now some of it totally cool
with some of it it's like look you were
in a shitty job and you wanted to uh
take a break re-skill see the world
retrain find yourself like all for it
that there are some
people though who are not going to do
anything particularly
developmentally positive and you know
maybe it's just going to become
and and so this is back to the seeds of
male failure right we're talking about
is that
let's say that you were a guy and you
like had to wear a business suit every
day and you like had meetings and you
know like you had you had to be in front
of people and it's like relatively
important so you're kind of being forced
to function at a high level
um now let's say that we make that stuff
virtual so now instead of having to put
on a business suit
um maybe you put on a shirt and then
you're wearing boxer shorts and it's all
waste up and you're just like doing zoom
from your house uh then you have to be a
little bit less on the ball
then maybe let's say i get rid of the
zooms even well you know you don't do
anything all day
like like men are kind of responsive to
our environments in that way and so this
is like the seeds of male failure we
talk about it's like i consider myself a
pretty high functioning
productive yeah
the rest of it um but there are guys
around me
um who are just chilling
and some of the chilling is not going to
lead to
positive places
i've felt this personally i always
thought i was like a pretty self-starter
type
i'm way better with some form of
structure
i will bend the rules of said structure
like when i was on wall street i started
a non-profit trying to make some money
but you know but
having that place to go that sense of
people i'm also an extrovert so seeing
people like i get energy like shooting
that's one reason why co-working spaces
had such appeal yeah you know it's like
having a place to go and you'd see
people you're part of something as an
environment you can
maybe make a business contact yes
the other piece the bigger piece of this
is um
it's maybe the republican of me saying
this but the the decline of the american
family sounds it seems catastrophic
and this is something that when i was
four people would label me as sort of
conservative i'm like look the data
shows clearly that kids brought up in
two parent households is just
much more like overwhelming positives
yes and so if you're like a republican
conservative
they did some stuff around marriage that
i was like sure like i said free
marriage counseling anyone who wants
anyone wants to try and keep the
marriage together
it's a societal win yes
and that was my question is that what
can the government do to keep
men and women married
get them married the single biggest
thing the government could do
would be to have stable prosperous
livelihoods for men
yeah because then the men would be like
all right i guess i i want to propose to
someone and then the woman would be like
i actually want to marry this yes right
and then you have kids that'd be two of
you and you know like the kid would have
a real shot the single biggest thing we
could do would be to create more jobs
for
uh for men of every educational level
and i think that's like back to my
original point our eyes off the ball in
the feminist movement and it pains me
because i think a lot of what i've
wanted to do is not say anything in that
letting the women this is like this is
the woman's movement like let's go like
it's about time we're behind as a
country and now it's like hey if we
forget about all the men were like
sidelining in this process who are
hurting to begin with
and don't focus on them it's going to
come back and bite everybody well here's
the problem is that
society pays an inordinate amount of
attention to the outliers so they're
going to be a whole host of male
outliers
that are going to make it seem like the
men are like you know running stuff and
like dominating yes and they are no no
even if the yeah even if the average
dude is languishing
if you just pay attention to outliers
you're going to see a bunch of dudes and
you're going to be like oh that like is
the dudes in charge [ __ ] that [ __ ] if i
want some kind of equity in the rest of
it i got to take it yeah yeah like the
rest of it but if you look at the rank
and file the average
like you know the the the average guy uh
is
you know not attending college and then
you know like uh not able to
find a
secure pass and at the margins that
person winds up self-destructive or even
uh externally destructive and here's the
other piece that man in power if his
relationship with his own masculinity is
destructive like maybe he came from
great back like you're gonna have in
order to get to that ceo level you're
going to have to have some sort of
structure around you whether it's two
parents or educational opportunities and
drive and
things like that but if he is
thinking with the wrong head
or has the wrong perspective on how he
should treat women this is where the
metoo stuff happens over and over right
and
if the maybe the feminist moves like get
that [ __ ] out of there and i agree
with that right like there's a certain
element of well so this is something i
you know this isn't part of what we've
been talking about but i suppose like
it's where my mind goes
um so the metoo movement i believe got
kicked off around a couple of monstrous
predators yes in the form of bill cosby
and harvey weinstein yeah who'd been
just complete like criminal predatory
some awfulness there yeah like again uh
like monsters like the word that just
sticks in my mind yeah and so there was
this rightful
let's get these guys you know like
the heck out of
society a position where they can do any
harm uh they should be in prison
like agree with all that i mean evelyn
was a victim of a serial predator right
a guy like that you're like who's being
you know like indicted right now and
belongs behind bars and institutions
cover that [ __ ] off yeah or bad or even
so that's why that stuff is very very
yeah that stuff is very very dark
there's like a lot of just like nothing
to see here institutionalization
um now that stuff
in my mind uh has
um not distinguished as much as it could
between behavior
like cosby's or weinstein's or dr
hadden's and like an al franken yeah
where like al franken did some stuff
that was off color and insensitive and
then was uh cast out in his case he you
know resigned uh from the senate i got
the sense that there was some regret
afterwards being like oh maybe that was
a little hasty um you know so that there
are like different degrees and there are
some people uh who say like no
harassment is harassment or like power
you know it's like it like abuses abuse
or something along those lines and like
a lot of reasonable guys look up and be
like wait like al franken is no he's not
harvey weinstein yeah he's no predator
of that scale at all because guys know
the seeds of dysfunctional masculinity
have sewed much deeper in a harvey
weinstein than they have frankie yeah
yeah so like guys jud like you can see
and be like oh that guy that like that
guy belongs behind bars for sure and
then when there's a guy who screws up in
a way it's like as a guy you'd be like
oh like i can see
uh myself screwing up that way i can see
a lot of people i know screwing up that
way and then when that person gets cast
out then you're a little bit like well
that doesn't seem right right because
like that's something that you know
isn't like as worthy of recrimination or
punishment so that is one principle i
think would be important is that if you
have um like a pro-woman movement which
i
agree with like you should make a
distinction between someone who does
something truly predatory monstrous
criminal and someone who's just an idiot
or like if there's a guy who makes like
a like an unwelcome pass at you and then
you don't like it and you shut it down
or whatever um
you struggle with it like and and then
you present it as like oh you know
there's like an unwanted advance and
like the rest of it's like like well the
person stopped then you know it's like
right
if you say you want if you think guys
are stupid you have to teach them right
like like how does that yes
yeah like where the line is now i'm not
saying that means i have to like sprint
past the line right but
for a young a young male to be
too grabby one time beca and learn the
hard way like
that is so different than harvey
weinstein and we need to talk about the
difference right that man can turn into
harvey weinstein right if not taught but
that man can also turn into a a gem
right
and that's what i'm talking about i mean
that actually is that's core i mean like
grabby is pretty
bad
okay you're right
so how you define grabby right like
let's get real like guys when i said
when i said i wanted to advance i i was
saying like uh you know like
you weren't like you know like you were
you like asked someone out in a clumsy
awkward way
i'm not talking about the guy who grabs
the ass of the waitress at a bar what
i'm talking about
is
a high schooler
making out with a girl
around second base or tries around
second base and gets his hand slapped
is that an unwanted advance yes it is
but the guy is
we're talking about a 15 year old
learning right now that woman could
probably go public and say he tried to
grope me and sexually assaulted me
and
i don't know if that's actually accurate
or maybe it was maybe it's too much or
maybe it's a guy learning um i don't how
does a guy learn if not now he's going
to ask every time there's there's
passion involved in this there's youth
involved in this i don't know as the
parent of two sons yeah like i i like
evelyn and i chat about this sometimes
it's like you do live in like a degree
of and in my case i'll just say like we
live in fear of them
uh becoming adolescents and like of
course developing a sex drive and just
generally because right now they're nine
and six and so there's
yeah yeah the rest of it but you see it
and christopher is autistic so he's very
very unmindful of social cues right and
so the odds of him saying or doing
something inappropriate very very high
right
and you do this and you factor in
hormones
social pressures high school pressures
college pressures drinking drugs alcohol
right
understanding that to me is core to
helping men but men and women but
particularly men understand their
masculinity learn what's right and wrong
[Music]
society-wide i i do think that we are
experiencing something of a breakdown of
the american male psyche
and the the big question is whether we
can manage through it if we don't try
and manage through it in an effective
genuinely empathetic way um with by the
way some effective policy measures that
help create livelihoods for men at
different
levels
of the educational spectrum
we're going to devolve into civil war
and the rest of it yeah like you know
almost certainly
and there isn't a whole lot of movement
in this space
um like if you say things that are
sympathetic to men you get beaten up as
oh i'm sure i'll get crushed for this
podcast
it's so there's like an
oversimplification in american life
where it's like you can be pro women
and
want to fix dudes like that that's like
to me those things actually ideally go
hand in hand i'm making the argument
that if i want to be pro women i got to
be pro men like that that sounds it's
ridiculous but that is my point i i
i don't know you have to agree with it
but i think i agree yeah that
if you want women to be treated better
in american life you would want to
cultivate and develop
strong men at every level of society
yeah and if you end up with weak men bad
[ __ ] will happen bad to everybody yes
because you know some of those dudes
will just like go this is one thing that
also bothers me uh and maybe it's
because i was an early asian kid growing
up but that like people talk about this
like contempt for
uh guys who just like go in the basement
like you know live in their parents
basement it's called in cells like in
voluntary celibates they play games and
there's such like contempt for that that
group of people it really bothers me
because
like i i feel like one i could have been
one of those people but two
um like
like why would you have contempt for
someone who's struggling in that way
it's just like uh you know like they
should be
people that you feel for like i feel a
great deal of empathy um for them and so
when people have contempt be like oh
like you know [ __ ] intel like [ __ ]
dudes in parents basement or whatever
i'm just like
you should be really concerned about
like those
those are the ones that shoot up schools
yeah and they're human beings and you
know like they they like have hopes and
dreams like everyone else what happens
is like when they're men whose hopes and
dreams don't work out they
tend to kind of go inward and they feel
like self-conscious and correct you know
like feel this sense like i am so
grateful
that because when i was young i felt
these things very very strongly
very strongly and you know like so
imagine this
i'm in my 20s uh you know i have a job
that most people consider good i leave
it to start uh
com that flames out and so like my
confidence is shot
i owe 100k plus in law school loans like
i when i
think about asking women out i feel
self-conscious about the fact that i
can't uh afford to like take them out on
a fancy date i get obsessed over the
fact that i'm worth negative six figures
even though they don't know that you
know and so like
all these things like like i didn't want
to
pay for a cab when we went someplace
because it was like you know too pricey
um
and so
you know the feeling man so so there was
like this feeling and i felt like this
angst and this anger
for so long and then if a woman didn't
like me i would think it was because
like i didn't make enough money or i
wasn't cool enough in that way
um like it's all like preying on me in a
particular way and i'm so grateful that
i
um got the time to mature through it i'm
super grateful for the level of success
that i had during that period which was
not a shirt at all because like you know
my company fails next company runs out
of money
um you know i was like throughout my
late 20s
things weren't going that well for me
professionally and my confidence was not
great my dating life wasn't great
and then it was really only when i got a
job that was a good fit for me
and then became
more
confident and positive and then i met
evelyn around the same time there was no
accident
um and so and this was in my early 30s
when it started to to
um really grow
so for guys who want that sense of
validation and progress
uh and not to get it you know like i i
feel for them
how did you get through it because
you're talking about
nine to
12 years there between
your first job it was really only about
seven years and they were difficult
seven years so like i graduated from law
school i was 24 i'm an attorney for five
months hate it uh leave to start a
fail.com and so the struggles then begin
okay at age 25. okay um so so it was so
it was 25 to 31 my mid to late 20s were
very very difficult for me
in this light and then when a
relationship went south or you know
again like a woman
you know wasn't into it or whatever
like i would just feel so bad about
myself and feel so deficient yes um what
did you do
i went to the gym a lot
i just like freaking pumped iron and
drank protein shakes and
brought it up that helped like it you
know i mean it's it's like you all have
different mechanisms
guys have but guys have mechanisms or if
they don't
and they let them creep up on them right
where some guys
um
you know like uh
i guess i'm saying there's destructive
ways and there's somewhat positive ways
to deal with it right like you went to
the gym
poured yourself into work right other
guys
will i mean get as drunk as they can and
try and screw anything that moves it
when they go to a bar right some guys
will
uh get addicted to pornography or drink
too much or drugs and escaping or
oh and and this is one of the things i
shared with you before is that there's
like a an arc of time where
if you go too long
it gets harder to
uh forge a healthy relationship it gets
harder to start a family you know it's
like a like a
so again feel very fortunate um but you
know i i did have those coping
mechanisms for those years
it was but like i do remember it being
really angsty and difficult
i was very angry and my confidence
really came and went
yeah for me it was um it was women it
was like i was like a serial dater i
just needed it was like the attention
validation i needed
to know if uh
that women liked me or that they could
go on a date with me or would date me
for a month or that sort of thing and i
would
i was like i broke up with my
i was like a girlfriend in college like
it's pretty serious and then we broke up
she was a year younger it's like didn't
work when i moved to city and so it was
just like not dealing with that
conceptually i didn't you know you know
she was great and i wasn't sure if
you're ever gonna get married but it's
more of like a
like it was a blow to the ego when you
when there's a breakup right so you just
find ways to numb it but i agree there's
like this when you're young in your
career it's tough to like
i was in the analyst programs there's
like so much like accolades or success
you could have at that age so yeah just
pour yourself into something that
distracts you
the thing i'm trying to figure out is
how do you scale that for other men you
know um one of my grand ideas when i was
running for president uh would be to
just have
mixed martial arts academies around the
country for free for free
and then have county competitions
statewide competitions
regional competitions and national
competitions where you essentially are
building like a giant tribe
of
guys who have a relatively healthy
outlet
beating the [ __ ] out of each other and
then just becoming like you know and
then they'd come together and like watch
their
champion compete against other champions
now some people would hear this and be
like this sounds like you know like the
broadest thing in the world or whatever
like i see it as like a very very
important pressure release or valve
because people need
a sense of belonging and competition and
purpose
uh and you need guys to be able to
channel that in positive ways or they'll
channel them in negative ways i think
bro is only bad when it's associated
with
being a fundamental [ __ ] or
mistreating women the big thing
and what my dad does with men's
ministries there's a bible verse as as
iron sharpens iron so does one man
sharpen another and i think that's so
[ __ ] true like men need to talk to
other men
because trying to navigate this alone
or even with women around you is just
not the same but men understand
this struggle instinctively it's
biological obviously by the numbers
right so
i agree it's it's outlets it's um
i mean we we have them somewhat right i
think sports are an outlet in that sense
video game right like but some of these
um some are healthier than others right
exactly they're not all great and
there's not enough um
and to me it's more just letting men
talk about it and so i i we had liz
plank on this podcast
and she's talked about letting boys cry
i don't agree with everything liz i
think she goes too too far on some of
this but i do think
what her and i agree with strongly is
that
a man's relationship to his masculinity
is um
you could argue it should be one of the
most important things the government
focuses on
which sounds ridiculous for a lot of the
things well you know and a lot of the
people we're talking about here would
think the government would [ __ ] this up
yes you're probably right but it
actually hasn't been that bad in um in
the past because a lot of that's do with
a strong economy um a strong economy you
know one of the major shapers
of men is the military you're right the
government's actually not bad at this
that would be my exhibit a yeah is like
hey that the military has taken a lot of
guys who would have been trouble
and
made them into high-functioning members
of society yes and
i think one of the biggest problems
actually
big problem with the military is when
they come back we don't continue that
like a lot of these men have
extreme structure um and they lose it
and that's a big problem big problem a
lot of people felt in coven so anyway
i'm glad we dove into this fixing
american masculinity
but not in the way that people
ordinarily talk about it because you
know when you say that and caitlyn
flanagan makes the this contrast between
heroic masculinity and toxic masculinity
right and that we need to talk more
about the former
like the the purpose that is very
positive around building things and uh
achievement in a positive way the man
the protector yeah looking out for
people
the decision maker at times um
like these are good traits yeah the they
are needed in a healthy society
self-sacrifice yes there is a male
male impulse around that yes and like
these are traits that are inherently
male
men do can do them and feel appreciated
when they do do them but when you're
told
your mask you're being too toxic in your
masculinity you have bro energy here you
have this or that i understand there is
sometimes truth to that right and
there's been a problem but we're
throwing the baby out with the bad bath
water um
and
i think it's hurting women just as much
as hurting men and that's that's my
that's my takeaway that's my that's my
soapbox for today
um
i'm glad we talked about this and it's
you know what this is andrew it's a
distraction from the morning i'm in
because the buffalo bills lost a
heartbreaker yeah that game was insane i
felt so bad for you in every bills fan
so after they go up by four points at 13
seconds left i was like
they win they win right they win
so like here's what i will say
and then i'm done
for 20 years we've been begging for a
quarterback like someone that could win
when the game's on the line to play at
an elite level he won he won that [ __ ]
twice we're down by four
he won that [ __ ] twice we're done by
four and he goes down drives down the
field and his two minutes left it was
fourth and thirteen we throw a touchdown
pass two minutes left in the game like
oh my god we're gonna win
and
then
patrick holmes comes down the field and
scores on us and one massive play we're
like oh my gosh so he has a minute left
and three timeouts and then josh allen
does it again i'm just thought it
happened quick when the chief scored
that touchdown i was like at least they
did it with time on it it was like when
i played madden i let them win because i
know i yeah it was almost like they let
them score a touchdown uh so the minute
left three timeouts and josh drives him
down the field again with this i mean he
was amazing he was absolutely insane we
scored touchdown 13 seconds left and i'm
like half me the bills fan of me is like
too much time too much time and then
patrick holmes two plays 45 yards gets
in a field goal range ties up the game
we go to overtime they win the coin flip
josh exhausted everyone's beat defense
gets blown like
josh allen doesn't touch the ball we
lose so it's like we finally get a
quarterback and he does it twice he does
it twice he did it twice and we didn't
win and it's so heartbreaking and
there's like all this stuff in the
national media how this was probably the
greatest playoff football game it was
ever um
and the greatest quarter i mean he's he
has the top quarterback performance of
two games in the playoffs in playoff
history josh allen that's our
quarterback and we lost um and so i
can't watch i can't look at the
commentary so this is my my venting
um thank you i thought for you man it
was it was an incredible game and it did
make me feel like for all the bills fans
out there
uh you lost in the most noble way
possible where it feels like if you just
win the coin flip you win yeah so we
played well it's like last year we lost
you played well enough to win you played
well enough to win you could even make
an argument you deserve to win yeah
agreed that's what that's what made the
game so good right um
patrick holmes is a freak uh but you
know you play that game in buffalo i
think we come obviously i mean we lost
on a coin flip on the road you could
argue like with a slight home field
advantage we win it um
so we gotta play better during the
season like we lost the job we had some
tough losses this year but
as much as look the bills are a young
core like you guys will be dealing with
me this will be backside
uh division two i mean yeah outside of
the patriots like it should be bad like
the jets will be bad for the foreseeable
and we will have a home afc championship
in buffalo and we will win it and go to
the super bowl and i will do this
podcast from there and it'll be
wonderful
uh all right y'all we'll see ya that's a
fitting way to end a conversation about
masculinity football we love you guys
see you next week
[Music]
you